the numbers are still horrendous but the
death rate is slowing in Italy the
lockdown here is working Rome still
silent North Italy was hit the hardest
by the contagion what happened there
shocked the whole country into a
realisation that the virus was coming
that they had to be ready for
nobody knew of the country's poorest
regions in the South could cope so it's
a beautiful morning in Rome but we're
often a foursome with two things we're
into another intensive care unit and we
want to see the effects this outbreak is
having on medical staff because many of
them are getting very very ill while
they're treating people and also there's
worries that Naples could to lose
control of the lockdown people are much
poorer in the south of Italy than they
are in the north and the less inclined
to stay indoors because they need to
earn money and they need to get food and
there's a great concern here that it
could get out of control so we're going
to look at
the sheer emptiness of huge motorways is
difficult to get used to but it is quite
something through spring mist we headed
south heading towards Naples
we glimpse Vasu vyas in the distance a
volcano that centuries ago brought its
own destruction every bit as deadly as
coated 19 the citizens of Pompeii didn't
heed the warnings back then of the
people of Naples today is it possible
that some hope for everyone in every
country could lie here in one hospital
where we're told not a single member of
staff has been infected and they still
haven't this is their story
right so in Naples now
and the waiting for us to wait to see
what it's like here but it's very very
different to the north
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is a whole different level to
anything we've seen before they're
wearing super advanced masks much nearer
to a gas mask than we normally see our
hospital staff wearing their thick
waterproof suits means the doctors and
nurses are effectively sealed in this
Nathan's infectious diseases hospital
now only treats Kovac 19 patients their
record of zero staph infections is
incredible it can be done you just have
to have the right gear and follow the
right protocols
there is a rush on here the patient
inside is deteriorating fast a nurse
prepares an injection outside the
treatment room he never goes inside
communicating through windows to
colleagues with the patient and they
never come outside during crisis moments
and this is one when it's ready the
medicine is passed through a compartment
door remember he's not been inside and
hasn't touched anyone or anything but he
immediately removes his gloves and
scrubs down this is an absolute constant
the lag between the epidemic sweeping
through northern Italy and overwhelming
the healthcare system before progressing
to the south gave this hospital precious
time to prepare cotugno
is the exception in the south it was
already the most advanced Hospital its
testing facilities of world class but
even here they're taking no risks they
may be working away from the patients
but they are in full protective gear the
vials are full of Kovac 19 virus put
bluntly it's distilled nastiness
mistakes here could be deadly
in this lab there try to figure out just
how immune you are once you've had Kovac
19 so what we don't know is if you can
be infected and then get it a second
time
yeah actually we don't know yet you know
second when you see a very thorough
query during the reading over is it not
this moment is not possible it's not
clear yet after a short term surely you
don't think again that we don't know
what is really striking here is the
rules of separating infected
environments and clean areas are
followed by everyone
[Music]
but armed security man every connecting
corridor in case anyone forgets were
moved back when the corridors locked
down as a new patient is brought in this
happens every time preparation is the
key to stopping the virus preparation
and equipment
is that speed with which things were
organized significant as a factor in
controlling the disease yes the
hospital's organized this is the first
first thing to do in this kind of
hospital
it's a doctor fiorentino and I was
organizing this to this to world and
it's very very important to support the
discreet and so on to organize our our
breasts i undress I will put a doctor or
nurse in the room I'll put your mask on
it's it's it's very important and also
you have to have the right equipment
yeah yeah we fight for we fight for
but however now we're this is a sub
intensive care unit
the patients are either recovering or
haven't deteriorated yet but the same
separation rules apply the red and white
line cannot be cross clean area nurses
and doctors assist infected area staff
across the line they keep the two
absolutely separated because in other
hospitals is it was too chaos all over I
get a number of infection yeah very high
yes yes in this hospital
nothing yeah that's incredible no
understa can go to clean area yeah so
doctor and to nurse
okay this is believe it
one question note at the moment you seem
to have the control of the numbers it
seems to be you know the figures aren't
getting any better but they're not
getting much worse what happens to the
hospital if there is a sudden surge to
get a point where you could we are ready
to - two beds in in a room and after we
have upset another so you could hang
because we are we start with visa after
one day the other
okay so it is growing each day you'll
have to open up another ward and across
the world as the pandemic spreads we're
seeing the number of infected and dying
jump every day health workers are right
on the front line and they're succumbing
to the illness every day perhaps though
it doesn't have to be inevitable it
isn't here the precautions are
meticulously observed
normally we do this removal of
potentially infected clothes it's called
doffing as a team we do it in an area we
choose cotugno they do it for you the
point is they are just doing it for me
they're doing it for themselves and
everyone outside nobody should get
infected they believe of course they
have the kid they doesn't just hope
what happened in Italy was a wake-up
call to the world it scared us all but
perhaps now it can bring us hope as well
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they don't sing as much as they used to
in ruining but as the dark days bright
they are sending that message of hope
[Music]
but the sky is always blue er they're
singing one day it will be everywhere
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you